okay hi everyone I'm gonna dive straight
in custom properties are now supported
in all modern browsers and this is great
it means what we're starting to see
examples of people using them in
production but they're different from
variables in pre processors and I've
already seen a lot of examples where
people are using them in a similar way
without necessarily considering what
specific advantages they have to offer
and that might include one European web
development conference as well but
that's okay I think custom properties
have a huge potential to change how we
write and structure CSS and to a lesser
extent as well how we use javascript to
interact with UI components now I'm not
going to focus much on the syntax and
how they work because what I think
separates the best players of any game
is strategy so I'm going to focus more
on the strategies today just can I get a
little bit of help I need a cursor okay
sorry about that okay
so custom properties are a little bit
like variables in pre-processors but
they have some very important
differences and one of the first and
most obvious differences is the syntax
so in sass we might have used a dollar
sign to denote a variable and unless we
use an @ symbol and custom properties
follow a similar convention and they use
a - - prefix to denote a custom property
so one other important difference that
you'll notice Gere is that we use a
different syntax for assigning a value
to a pretty than we do for retrieving
that value so when we're retrieving the
value we use this little var function
here and that'll be familiar to anyone
that's used things like calc or color
functions or mid max or any of the more
sort of functional parts of CSS that are
making their way into the modern
language so the next most obvious
difference is in the name they they're
called custom properties because they
really are CSS properties and in
pre-processors you can do almost
anywhere
this means outside declaration blocks
inside media rules you can even use them
as part of a selector and all of those
examples would be invalid with custom
properties so custom properties have the
same rules about where they can be used
as normal CSS properties in fact it's
far better to think of them as dynamic
properties than it is to think of them
as variables and this means that they
can only be used inside declaration
blocks or in other words between these
curly braces here and this means that
they're tied to a specific selector and
that can be the root selector and you
might have seen this in a lot of
examples but it can be any other valid
CSS selector and that can include inside
a media query so similarly you can
retrieve the value of a custom property
anywhere you would normally use a value
in CSS so this means that they can be
part of a single value or a shorthand
statement or they can even be used the
inside calc next to other set of
keywords and other values however they
can't be used inside media rules and
they can't be used inside selectors so
that means that things like nth child
are out as well which is a little bit
unfortunate because there's some
interesting things we could possibly do
with that okay so that ends my crash
course on custom properties there's
probably a whole lot more that you want
to know about the syntax and how they
work such as like how do we use fallback
values and can we assign custom
properties to other custom properties
and the answer to that one is yes but
this should be enough of a sort of
understanding so that we can get to know
some of the other strategies that I have
in this talk so cosmetic differences
aside one of the most significant
differences between variables and
processes and custom properties is how
they are scoped so we can refer to
variables as either statically or
dynamically scoped and pre-processors
are static so where CSS is concerned
static means that they're subject to
sorry static means that we can update
the value of a variable at different
points in the compilation process but we
can't change the value of the variables
that came before it so you can see even
though I'm using the same variable name
and targeting the same selector the
output or the generated says
on this side is going to be whatever the
value was at that time it was red and
this means that we could potentially
read an entire like dot s CSS file and
determine what the output is going to be
without knowing anything about the HTML
or any other inputs and that's not
something that we can do with custom
properties so custom properties work
differently where custom properties are
concerned dynamically scoped means that
they're subject to inheritance and the
Cascade and it means that this property
is tied to a selector and if the value
changes it affects all matching Dom
elements just like any other CSS
selector would and this is great because
it means that we can update the value of
a custom property using a media query or
a Havas state or JavaScript and we don't
have to change which custom property
we're using we just need to update its
value with CSS and I want to show you a
little bit of an example of this which
is why I was struggling to see the
cursor here before so if I apply this
example to my slides you can see that
the heading color has picked up this
light salmon and that's going to affect
all of my slides including the previous
ones there however I can scope this to
just slide 15 as well and you'll see
that none of the previous slides are
going to be affected any more so in
addition to being static or dynamic
variables can also either be global or
local and if you write JavaScript you'll
know what I mean here our variables can
either be applied to everything inside
an application or their scope can be
limited to specific functions or blocks
of code when custom properties are kind
of similar so custom properties are by
default locally scoped to the selectors
that we've applied them to so they kind
of like local variables however because
custom properties are also inherited
this means in many situations they can
behave a lot like global variables as
well especially if we're using them on
the root selector so they're kind of
global and when it comes to CSS we have
some things that are global and we want
them applied consistently across our
application things like typography
spacing colors
these are all examples of things that
you might want to apply globally and
consistently across your application and
here's an example from the famous Lonely
Planet style guide and it's got a
section called design elements which is
essentially about global concerns and it
contains things like the color palettes
and the typography and they have local
things too so for example a button
component and that's in a section called
UI components and when we use those
terms we're often talking about local
things so there'd be variables for these
two things like the color variations the
different sizes that we might have for
buttons and all of these would be local
variables and this is something that
we're pretty familiar with in CSS as
well in fact we've created things like
design systems style guides and naming
conventions javascript libraries all to
help with dealing with this problem of
global design elements and isolating
them from local component concerns and I
think that custom properties now provide
some new opportunities for dealing with
this old problem so as it turns out most
global things in CSS are also static
your brand colors your typography they
don't tend to change much from one
component to another and of course these
things can change but where they do it
tends to be sort of a global rebrand and
not something that happens very often on
any mature product and this is why I
think it makes sense to continue using a
preprocessor for static variables so
aside from helping keep sort of dynamic
and Static concerns separate in the code
it visually denotes static variables and
this means that you instantly know when
something is going to change globally or
when something's sort of more dynamic
and local and therefore we're probably
using a custom property and this will
make CSS a whole lot easier to read and
therefore easier to maintain now there
are a few small exceptions to this rule
and one of them is client-side theming
but for the most part I would call this
a 90% rule and it's one of the most
important strategies for working with
custom properties effectively and if
you're taking notes I think this is one
that you should possibly write down okay
so you might think that given my fairly
strong stance there on global variables
being
static that by reflection perhaps all
local things should be dynamic and
whilst it's true that local variables do
tend to be dynamic this is nowhere near
as strong as the tendency for global
things to be static and I think in many
situations it makes a lot of sense still
to have local variables that are static
or use preprocessors and that's
especially the case for more complex UI
components but of course complex UI
components don't make great slides so
I've come up with very simple example
here and again I'm using the example of
different size variations for a button
component now I use variables like this
mostly just as a developer convenience
and you can see that I've got things
like buttons small button medium and
button large and I prefix those
variables with the component name so
that I know that these are local
variables but you could use a different
prefix you could use something like C
for component or L for local or you
could even prefix global variables if
you wanted to whatever you choose to do
I think that it makes sense to
differentiate between local static
variables or preprocessor variables and
global static variables now if we take
this simple example and I decide that I
want all of the buttons to use the small
size on mobile devices or small screens
we suddenly have a more dynamic sort of
situation here and this is something
that means that custom properties
possibly make a lot more sense so
luckily we can assign preprocessor
variables to custom properties now you
might be wondering what this little like
hash and curly braces around the
variable are and the reason for this is
that dollar buttons small is actually a
valid value for a custom property and
recent versions of sass recognize this
so we need to interpolate these
variables and that's what this syntax
means and this tells SAS that you want
to output the value of that variable and
not Dollar button small in your style
sheet and this is only needed for
situations like this where variables are
also valid CSS or variable names are
also valid CSS okay so here you can see
that I've started off with a button
class and I've created a custom property
with a size of button small
now that class would be on all of those
buttons there so they all start off
small and then using a media query above
600 pixels I'm changing the value of
that custom property to either button
large or button medium and of course I
don't need to change the small one
because it stays the same
now what this results in is static
variables becoming locally dynamic so
you can still use a mix of two and if
you're refactoring this is a pattern you
might want to consider and then finally
here you can see that I'm retrieving the
value of that custom property just in
one place and once again it's only on
the button class which would be on all
of those buttons yet it's going to have
a different value depending on the
conditions above okay so just a little
deviation here hands up anyone who's
written an overly complex sass
abstraction only to get their hands
burnt a few people and hands up anyone
who's gone now back to using sass mainly
just for variables that definitely
describes my experience with with sass
and other pre-processors at least
initially and I read a really
interesting blog post on this topic
recently and it was on the free code
camp meet him it was called don't do it
at runtime do it at design time by Bill
Sawyer and he gave this example here and
I think this is really clever what it
does is it creates an array of letters
of the alphabet by looping over
different character codes and pushing
them into the array and obviously it's
like a really nice concise bit of code
it's smaller and it's gonna be faster
obviously than writing out all of those
values by hand but I agree with the
author the alphabet is not likely to
change and I want to see what's in that
array so code like this whilst clever
isn't necessarily helpful in a
production setting and the dynamic
nature of custom properties also allows
us to create some clever and complicated
abstractions so this example here
generates a modular scale so a modular
scale is like a series of numbers that
sort of relate to each other with a
given ratio and they're often used for
things like headings and font sizes and
spacing in web design and I could talk a
whole lot more about modular scales and
how we might use them because I'm really
interested in them but for this talk
what's interested about it is that the
modular scale is generated at runtime
using preprocessor sorry using custom
properties and the ratio there
so the value of each of these custom
properties is calculated using that
ratio and the value of the custom
property that came before it and what
this means is we can change the ratio
and all of those custom property is
going to be recalculated live in the
browser at runtime and I think that
that's pretty clever and custom
properties they won't be and they
shouldn't be immune to this kind of
experimentation and innovation and we do
this with new technologies and we did it
with pre processors as well but in the
long run I think that readable
maintainable code is going to win over
clever abstractions like this at least
in production and in production I might
like to see something a little bit more
like this so here I can easily read what
the value of each of those custom
properties is going to be and this is
good because we read code many more
times than we write it and once I
figured out what I think these values
should be it's not likely that these are
going to change much in my application
so that's why I think it makes sense to
generate code like this at design time
but of course this example here can
still be improved it violates the rule
earlier that sort of all global
variables should be static and I'd
consider these fairly global I'd much
prefer to make these preprocessor
variables and then convert them to
locally dynamic custom properties as
required using the techniques that I
showed you before with the buttons and I
think that it's also important to avoid
situations where we name custom
properties like this font size one font
size two etc because this can result in
us situations where we go from using one
custom property to a different custom
property and that brings me to my next
strategy and that is change the value
not the variable and once again this is
one of the most important strategies for
working with custom properties
effectively if you're taking notes
perhaps underline that one so
unfortunately I see a lot of examples
like this with custom properties so here
we have two custom properties one called
font size small one called font size
large and then using a media query I'm
switching from using the small to the
large one now this is exactly how we
would have done things with
preprocessors but with custom prospect
properties
this doesn't make a great deal of sense
so with custom properties a far better
way to do this would be to define a
single custom property and we scope that
to the component and in this case it's
the example component and as a general
rule we should never change which custom
property we're using for any single
purpose so with the media query I'm
updating the value of the same custom
property here and then once again in a
single place I'm retrieving the value of
that custom property and you'll notice
that the media query here is only used
to change the value of the custom
property not to not to retrieve that
value and there's very good reasons why
I've done this and you'll see this
pattern again throughout my talk and it
brings me to my next set of strategies
which is for responsive design so one of
the problems with responsive design when
it relies heavily on media queries is
that no matter how we organize our CSS
all of the Styles relating to particular
components become fragmented across the
stylesheet and it can be difficult to
know which CSS properties are going to
change so custom properties can help us
organize some of this logic related to
responsive design and make working with
media queries a whole lot easier
so my first strategy for responsive
design is if it changes it's a variable
and what I mean by this is if you're
using a media query or a Havas aid or
anything else to update the value of a
CSS property perhaps you place this in a
custom property and move it along with
the selector and the media query and
whatever else changes its value up to
the top of the document if done
correctly
this means that media queries will only
be used to update the value of custom
properties and as a result of that we
will have a clear separation of logic
from its implementation and this means
that all the logic will be at the top of
the document and whatever we see a vast
statement we immediately know that this
is something that changes in our CSS and
with traditional methods of writing CSS
there's no way of knowing this it
creates a link between logic and its
implementation and I find that
incredibly useful so the idea of
declaring variables at the top of a
document
is not a new idea it's something that
we've done in many programming languages
and it's something that we do with
preprocessors instinctively and it's now
something that we can do with regular
CSS as well so writing CSS in this way
creates a clear distinction between the
CSS at the top of the document and the
CSS below and I need a way to
differentiate between these sections
when I talk about them so I've come up
with this metaphor of a logic fold so
above the fold contains like all of the
preprocessor variables custom properties
and all the selectors that might change
those values and below the fold it's
highly decorative and straightforward
and easy to read and in fact it feels
like the kind of CSS we used to write
some years ago before media queries and
other complexities of the modern
language so this is what it might look
like above the fold and as you can see
here this section only contains custom
properties and more than that it only
contains examples where assigning values
to custom properties not reframing them
you might have figured out that this is
for a basic six column flexbox grid
system and I have a custom property
there called row display and then using
a media query I'm updating the value of
the row display from block to flex at
which point all of those Col basis
custom properties are going to come into
effect so below the fold I can see which
CSS properties are going to be changed I
know that the row class is using the row
display one for the display property
which isn't surprising and I can see
there too that the Col basis value is
used for the Flex basis and what's
interesting about that particular
example is the value of that custom
property is going to be different
depending on which of those classes is
applied in the HTML and it can make CSS
like that a lot less verbose we only
need one place where we're defining the
styles and I can look back above the
fold and I can see what those values are
going to be in the different situations
that might exist within the browser so
writing CSS in this way is easier to
maintain because all of the logic is in
one place and all the declarative code
is somewhere else it's easier to read
because we know what's changing anything
with a VAR statement without reading and
interpreting the whole style sheet as
many of us have become very good at
doing and what it will result is all the
styles or the design
concerns being in one place for each
individual component and separating the
logic from the implementation like this
is again another important strategy for
working effectively with custom
properties but of course all rules are
meant to be broken and that brings me to
my next set of strategies for seeming so
throughout this talk there's a lot of
places where I've already argued against
using custom properties for sort of
global dynamic variables and hopefully
I've implied that sort of assigning
custom properties to the route selector
is in many cases considered harmful but
like I said every rule has an exception
and for custom properties its theming
and I think that limited use of global
dynamic variables for theming makes a
lot of sense so theming generally refers
like updating the UI in some way it
could be something like the Twitter
profile page here changing the colors
the background image your profile
picture etc or it could also be
something more localized so for example
changing the color of a note in the
Google keep application or you might
have used a similar note applique know
keeping application like that
so theming usually involves compiling a
separate style sheet to user preferences
and this can be difficult it's also not
very performant because it means that we
might be rerender in the page in many
situations so with custom properties we
don't to compile these separate style
sheets all we need to do is put the user
variables or the user custom properties
up on the root selector and these can be
inherited by the default style sheet so
Ida and Doug are going to show you
something practical examples of theming
for accessibility later on but I want to
show you some strategies for not
stepping on your toes when you're
implementing some of those examples so I
think that we Beach should be very
deliberate and considerate about the use
of custom properties when it comes to
theming because these global dynamic
variables can be a lot harder to
maintain but luckily custom properties
are case sensitive and since most of our
custom properties are going to be local
if we're using dynamic global custom
properties it can make sense to
capitalize them so capitalization of
variables often signifies global
constants and for us this is going to
signify that the value of this custom
property might be
somewhere else in the application and we
probably shouldn't change it locally I
think that it can be useful to avoid
directly overriding these global theme
values and that's why I've used an
example like this so here I'm setting
the value of theme color to the value of
user theme color if it exists and then
this value here is a fallback value for
when the for when the user theme color
doesn't exist so if we're using theme
color throughout our application it's
going to fall back nicely whenever the
user hasn't set that preference so I
want to show you a quick example of this
here I've set the value of the
background to same color and I think
that if I apply this to my slides the
background color is going to change now
I want you to have a think about what
will happen I may use a theme color
available in the body here and the
answer might surprise well that we're
still falling back to this default value
here and the reason for that is the
value of user theme color hasn't been
set on the root element and that's where
we're sort of inheriting this value from
so obviously if I move this up to the
root that variables going to become
available in determining the theme color
and that can be a useful pattern if you
want over sort of restrict people from
overriding sort of these more global
values in different places in your
application also we've got something a
bit more complicated than this it can be
helpful to sometimes like expose those
variables with a star selector and what
this does is it makes the theme color
custom property of well on every element
and then that means that it's
recalculated for the body element and
we're now able to pick up the value of
that user theme color so I'm just going
to delete that and put my slides back to
the normal color okay so if you want to
set the value of custom properties with
JavaScript there's a fairly simple API
and it looks a little bit like this so
here I'm setting the value of the user
theme color to tomato and I'm doing that
on the document element there
which is the equivalent of the root
element so one of the really cool things
about this is if you have a technical
design team you can just sort of like
assign these variables up on the root
element there and then they can decide
how they should be used throughout the
stylesheet and this allows you to make
like large changes to how theming works
within your application without having
to touch any back-end code and without
necessarily even having to touch any
JavaScript so that can be really useful
as well if you're approving these values
from a database or if using like a
static site generator or even something
like react or view you can write these
custom properties out to style
attributes as well and these are going
to have greater specificity than any
defaults in the stylesheet so these
values are likely to be picked up if you
use correctly it's almost like a sort of
component level thing except that the
props here are said like passed in
through the style attributes and I find
that this is a really useful pattern
I've seen it used for things like
getting multicolored icons with SVG and
there's a whole lot of tricks you can do
with this pattern and I'm a big fan of
that okay so the final strategy have for
you is to start using custom properties
today even if you're supporting IE 10
and 11 you can start using some of these
techniques so much of what I've been
talking about today has to do with how
we write and structure CSS and this
means that we can use tools like post
CSS to write this out to a static
representation of the same code I use a
tool called post CSS CSS variables and I
know it's a little bit confusing but not
post CSS variables and not post CSS
custom properties the reason for that is
that some of those libraries they can't
determine what the custom properties are
going to be inside media queries and
other things they treat them a lot they
treat custom properties a lot like
static variables or a lot like
preprocessor variables but that first
one will do a lot better job of that
obviously this technique won't be able
to do some of the dynamic things like
some of the theming examples that I've
talked about but that might be okay it
might be perfectly acceptable for older
browsers to fall back to a default theme
and you apply theming and customization
as a progressive enhancement if you want
to know more about the specific
techniques that I use for said agenor
rating this come and talk to me
afterwards because I don't have time
unfortunately to go into the build
process okay so I know what you're
thinking here I think you Mike this is
greater but I haven't been listening
could you just give me the whole talk
again in one sentence so yes I can it
comes down to understanding the
difference between dynamic and Static
variables in CSS and a few simple rules
so global variables are usually static
separate logic from design if a CSS
property changes it might be a custom
property and change the value not which
custom property is used if you follow
these conventions you might find that
working with custom properties is a
whole lot easier than you think and it
might even change how you approach CSS
in general and yes that was one sentence
I didn't use a full stop okay so that's
it if you have any questions please come
and see me there's some other examples
that I would love to show people thank
you very much for your time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]